the guy that you partnered with with
that business
and i'm not a big fan of partners in
business unless there's like a true
compliment right like there's a good
synergy like
i think uh steve jobs wozniak are
probably one of the best examples
because jobs was the outside guy he was
the guy that would stand on the stage
and you know push the marketing he was a
big idea guy and then woz would sit in
the back kind of
you know making all the [ __ ] um but it
usually doesn't work out that way with a
business partnership i mean
the failure rate with business
partnership is probably just as bad as
marriage you know to be honest with you
it's probably even worse um
why did you think that that it was going
to work out like at the time why did you
sign up with a partner
um so at the time like number one i
wasn't familiar with it and this person
would seem to have been successful so
they had
some capital to invest and a software
background and you know i wouldn't
slander the guy this person is
absolutely brilliant like
when we were friends when we were
younger like one of the most uh
you know outstanding people i knew i
didn't know how much their mental health
had deteriorated
and also evolving in terms of like this
person would brag about manipulating me
to my face not to mention parties
and we talked out like interrupt and
talk down to me and pitch meetings and
that sort of stuff
so like clear clear was this early on or
was this into the partnership
so this was uh later in the partnership
there were signs of it earlier and i
wish i had just picked up on those and
put my foot down
but there really is i mean you talk
about a red pill for how men and women
interact
there's equally if not more detail in
terms of how
people interact in the course of a
business i'm personally not at all a fan
of 50 50 partnerships
i think no matter what it's going to be
asymmetric and there has to be somebody
who's the lead
and if there's somebody there who's like
actively stealing responsibility from
other people like won't let other people
make decisions
and then doesn't execute like that's the
most toxic possible
um combination you can get and there are
actually you know plenty of people who
fit that category some unwittingly
but um that's that's something to um
that i would always look out for and i
don't think i mean i think by having a
50 50 partnership you're usually asking
for trouble
like somebody has to be in charge yeah i
mean people that start at businesses are
um you know they're like you have to
have a degree of narcissism
to start up a business literally you do
it i mean you're just never going to be
successful unless you have some of the
narcissistic traits but at the same time
um my old business coach i had him on a
plane to win i think it might have been
two or three episodes back you guys can
go back i think it was episode number
26 or 27 with cameron he was saying that
almost all successful entrepreneurs that
he knows that are doing over a million
dollars a year in annual sales
are clinically or could be clinically
diagnosed as bipolar right
um it's you know it's a bizarre thing
because
you're celebrated when you go and create
something that has some impact and
you're often
um admired by many people but
nobody truly understands the kind of
crap that you go through
as somebody that's the founder or the
co-founder of the business because
playing the win is not easy it's
pretty [ __ ] hard actually um you know
like the mindset is the starting point
you